يومكم مستمرون معكم في تغطيتنا للاوضاع في
السودان الاتهامات المتبادله بين الجيش
وقوات دعم السريع انتقلت من المسؤوليه عن
خرق هدنه ثلاثه ايام المعلن عنها الى
المسؤوليه عن فرار عدد من رموز نظام
الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر البشير من سجن
كوبر
[موسيقى]
والبدايه من تداعيات هروب عدد من رموز
النظام السابق من سجن كوبر بالعاصمه
الخرطوم حيث اكد الجيش السوداني ان الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير لا يزال محتجزا بمستشفى
عسكري تحت حراسه الشرطه القضائيه قال
الجيش في بيان له ان البشير وعددا من
قيادات حزبه محتجزون في مستشفى علياء
العسكري الجيش عبر عن رفضه لاي محاولات
لربط ما يجري في السجون بمزايدات على
مواقفه الوطنيه ووصف الجيش السوداني الدعم
السريع وقائده بانهم امتداد للنظام السابق
اما الشرطه السودانيه فحملت قوات الدعم
السريع مسؤوليه اطلاق سراح السجناء
بالاضافه الى الجرائم المرتكبه بحق
المواطنين واكدت الشرطه ان الدعم السريع
اطلق سراح النزلاء في سته سجون بالخرطوم
والولايات الشرطه قالت ايضا ان قوات الدعم
السريع اقتحمت سجن كوبر وتسبب في مقتل
وجرح عدد من قوه الشرطه
في المقابل اتهم المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع يوسف عزت تهم قيادات
مواليه للبشير في الجيش بالمسؤوليه عن
اطلاق سراح قيادات نظام السابق من سجن
كوبر واضاف في تصريحاتنا العربيه ان
مغادره قيادات نظام البشير للسجن كان امرا
متوقعا
اليوم
الاول نتوقع كل هذا العناصر الاسلاميه
داخل الجيش انا لا اتهم كل الجيش الجيش
ليس كله حركه اسلاميه هنالك ضباط شرفاء
ولكن هنالك جهات داخل الاستخبارات
العسكريه هنالك جهات ضباط اسلاميه ساهموا
في اطلاق سراحه هذه المجموعه نحن لدينا
معلومات من داخل السجن لحظه اطلاق النار
لحظه اقتحام السجن لحظه اطلاق سراحهم ولكن
كانت قواتنا لم تكن قريبه من الموقع
للسيطره على هذه العمليه
عزه قال ايضا للعربيه ان من المسؤوليه
الدعم السريع القبض على من فروا من داخل
سجن كوبر انا
لا تنفيذ العمليه او كيفيه اخلاقه من
السجن اؤك هذا هذا مجرد توقعات او
احتمالات او لاشخاص فيهم احمد هارون في
يوم عبد الرحيم محمد
مسؤوليتنا وفي اطار حربنا
والذي يواجهون نبيها
سنسعى بكل ما يمكن ان يقبض القبض عليه
اقدم سجنا في السودان افتتح عام
1903 يقع في حي كوبر بمدينه بحري قرب
النيل الازرق نسب اسمه الى الجنرال
البريطاني كوبر الذي تولى اداره السجن
مساحته 5000 متر مربع وتصميمه يحاكي سجون
بريطانيا يضم محكومين سياسيين وجنائيين
وشهد اعدامات الضباط [__] 14 قسما من
بينها قسم مخصص للمدانين باحكام الاعدام
وقسم لاصحاب السوابق واخر لذوي الاحكام
الطويله والقصيره وقسم للمعتقلين
السياسيين كان يضم الرئيس السابق البشير
وعددا من قيادات نظامه غادره عدد من
قيادات نظام البشير على خلفيه تدهور
الامني في البلاد
اذا من هو احمد هارون القيادي في نظام
رئيس السوداني السابق عمر البشير الذي
ابدى استعداده هو اخرون للمثول امام
القضاء رغم الفرار من سجن كوبر نتابع
احمد هارون
من مواليد عام
1965 بمدينه الاوبيض
ينتمي لقبيله عربيه من شمال كردوفان
درس القانون بجامعه القاهره وتخرج عام
عاد الى السودان ليعمل في السلك القضائي
قاضيا
من العناصر البارزه في الحركه الاسلاميه
السودانيه
تم تعيينه وزيرا للشؤون الاجتماعيه في
ولايه جنوب كردفان
عين وزير الدوله في الداخليه عام 2003 بعد
ارتفاع وتيره التمرد في اقليم دارفور
اختلف مع قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو ما جعل الرئيس البشير يتدخل
للصلح بينهما
دخلنا في المشاكل وجاب لنا سمعه البطاله
احمد هارون يا اخي احنا ما ملائكه 6000
تراس هارون لجنه امن دارفور التي تتهمها
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بتجنيد وتسليح
الجنجويد وارتكاب انتهاكات واسعه
عين واليا لجنوب كردفان ومن ثم وليان
لشمال كردفان
اثار هروب قاده نظام البشير من سجن كوبر
في العاصمه الخرطوم اثار جدلا واستهجانا
بين السودانيين وبعض القوى المدنيه التي
اعتبرت هروب هؤلاء هي محاوله لتوسيع الحرب
فمن هم ابرز الفرين وما هي المناصب التي
شغلوها
قيادات نظام البشير يغادرون سجن كوبر الى
جهه امنه
الفارون قالوا انهم سيؤمنون الحمايه
لانفسهم ابرز هؤلاء الوزير الاسبق احمد
هارون عينه البشير منسقا عاما للشرطه
الشعبيه اتهم بارتكاب جرائم حرب في دارفور
عندما كان يشغل منصب وزير الدوله علي
عثمان طه البرلماني والوزير السوداني
الاسبق شغل حقيبتي التخطيط والخارجيه ثم
نائبا اولا للرئيس عمر البشير رجل الامني
نافع علي نافع مدير جهاز الامن العام
والامن الخارجي شغلها منصب وزير الزراعه
ومساعدا للبشير حينا وزيرا لديوان الحكم
الاتحادي ونائبا لرئيس حزب المؤتمر الوطني
الحاكم رجل الاقتصاد عوض الجاز شغل حقائب
وزاريه منها التجاره والطاقه وشؤون الدوله
تنسب اليه تهم بالفساد واداره اموال
الحركه الاسلاميه في الخارج ابراهيم
السنوسي مساعد البشير ورئيس مجلس شورى حزب
المؤتمر الشعبي يتهم السنوسي بانه احدى
الشخصيات المشاركه في انقلاب
1989 الذي جاء بالبشير الى السلطه
ونذهب الى شبكه الضيوف العربيه ضمن هذه
التغطيه نبدا من الخرطوم الدكتور علاء
الدين نقد المتحدث الرسمي باسم تجمع
المهنيين السودانيين وعضو المجلس المركزي
في قوه الحريه والتغيير مرحبا بكم معنا
دكتور علاء الدين في سياق هذه التغطيه كيف
يتابع تجمع المهنيين السودانيين وقوى
الحريه والتغيير عموما هذا الظهور السياسي
في هذا التوقيت بالذات لاحمد هارون
المسؤول السابق في نظام البشير بعد ان
اعلنت القيادات في نظامه مغادره سجن كوبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف
الرحمه والمغفره للشهداء والقتل الذين
فقدناهم في ايام الحق
المصابين
ودعواتنا القلبيه الكبير للسودان الخروج
من هذه المحنه طيب شكرا استاذنا وجميع
العاملين في قناه العربيه على ضيوفك
الكرام حقيقه يعني ظهور
عناصر النظام البائد بهذا
المشهد وخروجهم في بيان يعد انتكاسه كبيره
جدا جدا حقيقه يعني
انتكاسه للثوره
ولكن تاكيد على ان هذه الحرب العبثيه التي
قامت اليوم 15 من ابريل
حقيقه هي
قامت يعني بسبب هؤلاء وافرادهم
الموجودين في الحياه العامه سواء كان في
صحفيين اعلاميين الذين كانوا ينصرون
سمومهم منذ بدايه العمليه السياسيه
والاتفاق الاطاري والوعش الخمسه المختلفه
للاتفاق الايطالي وبالتحديد ورشه الاصحاح
الامن العسكري الاخيره
وكانوا يشعلون الحرب بين الجيش وبين دعم
السريع وكذلك افراد
اعضاء النظام البيئي الداخل القوات
المسلحه التي كثيرا في اللقاءات الكثير من
اقر بها الكثير حتى من المحللين المحايدين
هم الذين ساقوا الجيش والدعم السريع لهذه
الحرب لا كانت جيش كمؤسسه ولا دعم سريع
يرغب بالانقراض في هذه الحرب ولا ولا
الدين لكي نفهم اليوم
حتى اذا وصلنا الى هنا من له مصلحه اليوم
لاعاده خلط الاوراق واشراك جماعه نظام
البشير في الاحداث الحاصله في السودان
مؤخرا
او افراد نظام البشير هم نفسهم الاخوان
المسلمين هم الذين لديهم
الرغبه في ان يعودوا الى السلطه مره اخرى
والا
لما يعني احمد هارون في خطاب مثل هذا يعني
هذا الخطاب في هذا التوقيت يدل على نفهم
هؤلاء الشديد بالعوده للسلطه يعني حتى
كشفوا انفسهم كان كان يمكن لهم الاختباء
على الاقل على الاقل حتى تن
جلي هذه ما
[موسيقى]
حدث فانهم انهم مهمهم الكبير للسلطه يعني
حتى غطى اعينهم وقشفوا انفسهم وظهروا في
هذا البيان ووضحوا انهم يصطفون مع الجيش
في معركته التي اسموها بمعركه الكرامه
حقيقه هم يعني هذه كانت يعني اوقعوا
انفسهم بانفسهم في في هذا وحتى ان كثيرا
من اعلاميهم وصحافييهم الذين كانوا يؤجدون
نار الحرب قبل ان تبدا والذين كانوا
يؤيدون ان لا تكون هناك هدنه لوقف اطلاق
النار بحجج
العمليات الانسانيه
تبوا في كتاباتهم ان هذا خطا استراتيجي
ظهور احمد هارون وانه قد لخبط علينا كل
اعمالنا الدكتور علاء الدين يعني هناك
اتهامات تطال قوى الحريه والتغيير بانكم
جزء ويتحمل المسؤوليه الكبيره مما الت
اليه الامور في السودان اليوم جراء
الانقسام وانقسام من قبل قوى الحريه
التغيير والصفافها الى الطرف دون غيره
اليوم في المعادله طبعا المدين هذا
الاتهام حيكون موجود ده محاوله للووي عنق
الحقيقه اي احد سيستخدم هذه الاتهامات لكن
حقيقه الامر ان اقول الحريه والتغيير وقول
مقفاق الايطالي كثيرا ما نبهت ان الاتفاق
الاطاري والعمليه السياسيه هي السبيل
الوحيد الموجود لكي نخرج من البلاد الى
بره الامان ونمنع انزلاق البلاد الى هذا
الهاويه وان تعدد الجيوش هو السبب الاساسي
المضر بالانتقال الديمقراطي فلنضع
عمل جيش مهني واحد وتكوين جيش مهني واحد
هو اهم الاولويات وفرزت لذلك ورشه كبيره
جدا حضرها
خبراء من الخارج فيها الكثير من الاوراق
هذه الورشه وضحت حقيقه الامر ان ورقه
القوات المسلحه التي قدمتها لا تقوم على
اسس الديمقراطيه وهي ان تكون القوات
المسلحه تحت السلطه المدنيه وتكون
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه من اختصاصك ولكن
اذا ما تحدثنا على القوه السياسيه نفسها
هي كانت ترفض في الاساس مقترحات الجيش في
اشراك قوى سياسيه اخرى في الاتفاق الاطار
يعني
القوه السياسيه التي يرغب الجيش ان يشركها
ولماذا اصلا يرغب الجيش ان يشرك هذه القوه
اذا عدتي
القوه السياسيه التي يريد الجيش ان
يشريكها هي نفسها من اجتمعت امام القياده
العامه القصر الجمهوري قبل في الاعتصام
قبل اعلان الانقلاب وطالبت الجيش بان يعلن
بيانه للانقلاب على الحكومه الانتقاليه
فكيف لك ان تتخيلي ان قوه سياسيه او قاعده
الجماعات مسلحه اجتمعت امام قصف تدعو
الجيش للانقلاب على فطر انتقاليه تكون
داخل اتفاق لماذا جاء هذا الاتفاق
الايطالي من الاصل وما الذي اتى به
نظرا لمقاومه الشعب ومقاومه القوى
السياسيه للانقلاب وليس
بسبب قوه سياسيه وقفت مع الانقلاب وجاءت
بالانقلاب وشكل
ت حرف فهل من المعقل فهل من المعقول ان
تكون الاتفاق الاطاري الذي جاء ليضع حدا
للانقلاب ان تكون من ضمن القوه السياسيه
الموجوده فيه قوه سامده الانقلاب وقوى
حضنه الانقلاب وشكلت الحاضنه السياسيه
الانقلاب
المعقول وبالتالي بعد كل هذه المستجدات
والتطورات الحاصله من غير المعقوله نتخيل
اليوم اقله في الوقت الراهن ان يعود وتعود
جميع الاطراف الى الطاوله مجددا خصوصا في
ما حديث عن اتفاق قطار جديد اختم معك من
الخرطوم دكتور علاء الدين نقدي المتحدث
الرسمي باسم التجمع المهنيين السودانيين
وعضو المجلس المركزي في قوى الحريه
والتغيير شكرا جزيلا لك نتابع معكم
مشاهدينا ونحن نعرض لكم جديد المشاهد
المتعلقه بعمليات الاجلاء اكبر عمليات
اجلاء وصلت وحصلت اليوم ما زال عدد كبير
من الرعايه يصلون عبر البحر من ميناء
بورتسودان الى ميناء جده وتحديدا قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه في جده التي استقبلت
الان اكبر عمليه اجلاء لحوالي
1687 شخصا جاؤوا من 58 جنسيه
عن سادس يوم لعمليات الاجلاء من كافه دول
المنطقه ولكن السعوديه هي تشرف على الجزء
الاكبر من عمليات الاجلاء طبعا نظرا لقرب
جده اكثر من البلدان الاخرى
لميناء بورت سودان تحديدا اذا ما تحدثنا
عن شرق السودان من ناحيه جغرافيه بالتالي
سفينه امانه تحمل الامانه من السودان الى
السعوديه ومن السعوديه هي المحطه الثانيه
حتى تنطلق الى دول الجنسيات والرعايه
الذين وصلوا اليها بحثا عن منطقه اكثر
امنا بحثا عن الامان هروبا من حده
الاشتباكات التي طرات في الاونه الاخيره
والتي ما زالت تحصل فيها خروقات رغم الهدن
المعلنه بين الطرفين نتحدث الان عن هدنه
رابعه ثلاث هدنه عيد الفطر على كل حال
نذهب الى مراسل العربيه من ميناء جده هاني
صفيان هاني مرحبا بك معنا في سياق هذه
التغطيه الكلمه لكي توضح لنا جديد
معايناتك وجديد مشاهداتك حتى الساعه
[موسيقى]
نعم اهلا بك مجددا العربيه ما زالت تواكب
وصول بعثه الامم المتحده هنا في ميناء جده
الاسلامي وتحديدا عبر الفرقاطه الفرنسيه
لورين والتي سمحت لها السعوديه بالوصول
الى مدينه جده لنقل واجلاء رايه بعثه
الامم المتحده وعددهم يصل الى 400 شخص من
جنسيات مختلفه طبعا ما زالت عمليه الجلاء
او عمليه نزول
الاشخاص علمتني الفرقاطه متواصل هذه صوره
من صور وصول عدد من عدد من بعثه الامم
المتحده التي وصلت الان للتو من جنسيه
متعدده طبعا قبل ايضا نود ان نذكر ان هناك
ست حالات على متن هذه الرحله او على هذه
الفرقاطه هم مصابون او تعرضوا لحالات صحيه
وكذلك ج اثناء رحلتهم بعضهم ايضا جرار بعض
الشظايا التي وصلت او طالت الشظايا الى
جسدي جراء النزاعات التي تحدث بين طرفي
النزاع الان في السودان ولكن حالتهم
مستقره وتم نقلهم عبر اسعافات الهلال
الاحمر السعودي وكذلك التاكد من صحتهم من
قبل وزاره الصحه السعوديه التي تتواجد على
الرصيف ميناء جده الاسلامي وهم يتواجدون
الان للتاكد من صحتهم وسلامتهم واعطائهم
اللقاحات الوقائيه وبعد ذلك يتم توجه بعثه
او رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده الى الحافلات
التي خصصت لهم هناك عناق حار جدا هناك
التقاء بين عائلتين لم يشاهدها بعض او
انهم او انهم يتحمدون بالسلامه لم يتوقعوا
الوصول الى ميناء جده الاسلامي كنا ناخذ
لبعض الاشخاص الذين وصلوا وكانوا يتحدثون
عن فعلا ان الرحله شاقه وليس فقط الرحله
ولكن المشاهد التي شاهدوها كانت مؤلمه
وحزينه بحسب ما وصفوك عموما نحن نرصد ما
يدور الان ونحن ايضا ننقل ما يقولون ونرصد
الان تحديدا الخطوه الاخيره قبل توجه
رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده الى حافلاتهم
وهو من قبل الجوازات السعوديه التي تقوم
بالتاكد من جوازاتهم وكذلك معلوماتهم حتى
يتم بعد ذلك توجههم الى الحافلات التي سوف
تقول لهم الى مقر اقامتهم في مدينه جده
طبعا السعوديه اليوم في اطار عملياتها
الانسانيه التي تقوم بها سواء عبر السماح
لعدد من السفن والفرقاطات من دول عده
باجراء رايها وايضا اخذ مدينه جده ورصيف
ميناء جدا الاسلامي تحديدا كمنطقه عبور
منطقه سلام وامان وبعد ذلك مغادرتهم من
جده عبر مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
المدني الى بلادهم وهي محطه
ايضا استراحه ووصول الى بر الامان من اجل
رعايه رعاياهم الذين
بعضهم ايضا لديه بعض الاصابات الطبيه سواء
لبعثه او رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده او
كذلك الجنسيات المختلفه طبعا كانت هناك
اليوم او في ساعات الصباح الاولى ايضا نود
ان نذكر كانت اكبر عمليه اجلام قامت بها
السعوديه عبر سفينتها السعوديه امانه
والتي نقلت من خلالها اكثر من 1600 او او
1670 شخص من اربعين جنسيه
اقلتهم السعوديه الى جده وبعد ذلك تم
الوقوف من قبل سفرائهم والتاكد ايضا من
صحتهم وايضا سلامتهم وتم نقلهم بسلام الى
مقر اقامه هناك عده فنادق وفرتها السعوديه
من اجل رايه المواطنين اليوم تحديدا نتحدث
عن مدينه جده ولماذا جده لقربها من ميناء
بورتو سودان واليوم موقع جده الاستراتيجي
او السعوديه الاستراتيجي وايضا
السماح والاستجابه السريعه التي قامت بها
السعوديه
للطلبات التي قدمتها دول عده من لاجراء
رعاياها من من السودان جراء النزاع الذي
يحدث الان ساعد دول عده واغلى دول عده في
انها تقوم باجراء عليها الى جده وبعد ذلك
يتم نقلهم اما عن امبرا طائرات خاصه من
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه او كذلك عبر
الطيران المدني وهو عبر مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي في مدينه جده مازلنا نقوم
برصد الن الرعايه بعثه الامم المتحده من
فرقاطه لورين هذه الفرقاط التي اعتادت ان
تزور السعوديه ولكن تزورها في عمليات
مشتركه عسكريه مع وزاره الدفاع او ضمن
تمارين مشتركه مع وزاره الدفاع السعوديه
ولكن اليوم هي تقف وتزورها وهي تحمل على
متنها رعايا لبعثه الامم المتحده بعد ان
استصعب بهم الامر مغادرتهم من السودان
طبعا هناك ايضا كان من حديث السيد الطيب
ادم وهو ممثل بعثه الامم المتحده والذي
تحدث للعربيه ان هذه الدفعه هي الدفعه
الاولى وهناك دفعه اخرى سوف تصل غدا او
بعد غد اجمالي عدد بعثات الامم المتحده
قرابه الالف شخص هم متوزعون على دفعتين
الدفعه الاولى الان تصل والدفعه الثانيه
سوف تصل غدا او بعد غد وما زالت العربيه
ترتكب عمليه وصول هذه الدفعه سواء
للفرقاطه او كذلك للدفعات الاخرى اما
الجويه او البحريه التي تصل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه او الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي او حتى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في مدينه جده غرب السعوديه
في كل التفاصيل خصوصا هذه المشاهد
المباشره حتى هذه اللحظه بالتاكيد هاني
يعني كما تعلم دائما البعثات الدبلوماسيه
بشكل عام وبعثات الامم المتحده عندما تقرر
ان تخلي مقراتها وان تقوم بعمليه اجلاء
لرعياها والممثلين الهيئه الدبلوماسيه
لديها معلومات استخباراتيه او تقييم
مراقبين في الوضع على الارض بانه يجب
اخلاء هذه المنطقه اصبحت غير امنه فورا هل
لمستم من خلال احاديثكم مع من وصلوا ميناء
جده الاسلامي بانهم في رحله قصيره مؤقته
قريبه العوده الى السودان ام لا يعني هناك
رحله طويله وقد تكون طويله الامد لحين
الرجوع الى السودان
يبدو ان الرحله طويله خاصه عندما شاهدنا
البكاء وايضا تحدث الكثير بالام التي
واجهوها
سيده مسنه كانت تتحدث لنا كانت الرحله
شاقه شاقه وهي تتنهد وقلت لها لماذا
تتنهدين وانت تقولين شاقه هل من اجل
الرحله امر اخر فقره شاق من كل شيء ومؤلم
من كل شيء السودان انتهى هكذا صاغت هذه
الصيغه وهي ايضا من بعثه علوم متحده وهي
تحمل الجنسيه السودانيه هذه تعتبر مواطنه
وايضا احد رايه بعثه الامم المتحده فعندما
تتحدث فانها شاهدت الالام وشاهدت ايضا
الماسي وشاهدت ايضا الكوارث وشاهدت ايضا
تنقلاتها وانتقالها من الخرطوم الى بورت
سودان وخاصه عندما تتحدث سيده مسنه عن هذه
الالام فهي خبيره وتعي بما تقوله
ارقام وهناك بيانات قال ان الامر يفتقد
الى وجود بيانات فنحن لا نستطيع السير
تحدث بهذه اللغه فعندما يتحدثون موظفون
راعي الامم المتحده بهذه الصيغه فهم
يتحدثون عن امر قد لا ترصده كاميرا ولا
تكتبه ولا يكتبه قلم ولا يستطيع ان ايضا
ينقله سيده ولكن دعني اخذ لقاء الحمد لله
على سلامتك الله يسلمك
كنا نسال سيده عن الرحله كانت تقول الرحله
شاقه الرحله شاقه لكنها المريس كانوا ناس
ماذا عن حال السودان الحمد لله
الحمد لله ربنا ينفعنا
يا رب يا رب
بس
من كذا
لماذا تبكين
انا طالعه من الوطني ما حاجه سهله
ربنا ينصرنا يا رب هل انت متاكده بان
اهلكم هناك سوف يكونون بامان ان شاء الله
تفائلوا تخيل تجدوه انت متفائله ولكن
الحمد لله برضه لسه انا متفائله لا ان
تكسر الحمد لله على سلامتك ويعطيك أسلمة
الله يسلمك شكرا لك الله يبارك فيك اذا
سيده اخرى هي متفاعله تقول تركنا اهلنا
خلفنا وما زلت متفاعله وسالتها هل تعتقدين
انهم سوف يكونون بامان قالت ما زلت
متفائله اذا الامر هو واضح بين التفاؤل
وبين الالم والايام سوف تكون فيها التفاؤل
وقد تحدث فيها الالم ولكن نتمنى ان شاء
الله ان يحقق التفاؤل وايضا تزول هذه
الكارثه ايضا التي تعتبر كارثه انسانيا
قبل كل شيء وخاصه من العمليات التي
نشاهدها
شكرا
وفي تداعيات الازمه الصحيه المتفاقمه جراء
الاشتباكات المستمره قال الناطق باسم
الهلال الاحمر السوداني اسامه ابو بكر في
حديث العربيه ان صيدليات في العاصمه
الخرطوم مغلقه مع وجود امدادات شحيحه في
الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه وضعف ان
مستشفيات العاصمه تعاني بسبب شح الوقود
الضروري للمولدات الكهربائيه عادا عن
النقص الكبير في الطواقم الطبيه
المستشفيات الان زي ما انتم كلكم عارفين
في التقارير بتاعتكم انه فيها شح كبير جدا
في كل الاشياء من ابسط المعينات او
المستلزمات الطبيه للعلاجات الى
القطوعات بتاعت الكهرباء والماء
وصعوبه تشغيل مولدات الطاقه الكهربائيه
لانه في شحف الوقود اللي بيشغل هذه
المولدات في نقص كبير جدا جدا في الكوادر
الطبيه
يعني الاطباء والمستعدين والجراحين
ومساعدين الطبيين والممرضين
في وضع كارثي جدا وفي نفس الوقت الاعداد
بتاعه المصابين
والمتوفين كبيره جدا
ابو بكر شاره في حديث العربيه الى وجود
نقص حاد في المواد التموينيه مشيرا اذا
استمر الوضع طويلا قد تحصل مجاعه في
العاصمه السودانيه لتوقف سلاسل انتاج في
المصانع والمخابز المع
اناه التموينيه طبعا
المواد التموينيه واذا استمر الوضع لا قدر
الله على هذا المنوال لزمن شويه طويل
هتحصل مجاعه اكيد في الخصوم لانه تعطلت
سلاسل الانتاج يعني المخابز
بسموها ايه هي المصانع اللي تطحن الدقيق
للتوزيع لنقاط التوزيع وللمخابز ففي شروح
كبير جدا جدا
نذهب معكم الى هذه الصور المباشره الان من
محيط مطار الخرطوم اذا نتابع معكم هذه
الصور الهدنه اليوم في يومها الثاني هي
الهدنه الرابعه بعد هدنه عيد الفطر ولمده
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه هناك بعض الخروقات
ولكن الهدوء الحذر هو سيد الموقف حتى هذه
الساعه وفق مراقبين امنيين وعسكريين على
الارض في السودان يعتبرون بان هذه الهدنه
تعتبر الافضل من حيث حجم الهدوء الحذر حتى
هذه الساعه اذا ما قرنت بسابقاتها
ونظيراتها من الهدن التي تلت الساعات
والايام الاولى من تصاعد الاحتجاجات
والاشتباكات وايضا تصاعد الصراع المسلح
بين قوتين عسكريتين في السودان نتابع معكم
هذه الصور من محيط مطار الخرطوم حتى هذه
الساعه طبعا الصوره اختلفت اذا ما قرناها
في
المقبله والايام في الايام السابقه حقيقه
كان هناك تصاعد مكثف للدخان كان هناك
اصوات للاعير الناريه وايضا لذويلي
القذائف فيما الان تبدو الامور افضل من
ناحيه اذا كما نتابع معكم هذه الصور
والمشاهد الان
نستمع الان قليلا الى الصوت الطبيعي
لا اله الا الله على كل حال كل ذلك
يتزامن مع ازمه معيشيه ازمه انسانيه يشكي
منها المواطن السوداني ايضا الامم المتحده
كانت حذرت عن ان 15 مليون سوداني هم بحاجه
الى دعم انساني عاجل وسط نقص كبير في
المستلزمات الاساسيه مقومات الحياه
الاساسيه وايضا ارتفاع جنوني في اسعار
المواد الغذائيه ونفاد كثير منها من
الاسواق طبعا نذهب الى الخرطوم الان
لمعاينه الوضع الصحي معنى هناك الدكتور
هويدا محمد الحسن عضو منظمه اطباء السودان
من اجل حقوق الانسان دكتوره هويدا مرحبا
بك معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه اولا هل
استفاد الجسم الطبي من في الهدنه رغم بعض
الخروقات لمزاوله عمله في تقديم الرعايه
الصحيه
والاسعافات الاوليه اولا
السلام عليكم كيف الحال وشكرا لقناه
العربيه
حقيقه الوضع اسوء الان الوضع لانه الان
نحن في موقف صعب لا نستفيد حتى
لماذا وكيف
وكيف الان الانسان السوداني لا يموت فقط
من الرصاص
هذا
الاخت الينا الاطفال مرضى السكري مرضى
السرطانات
السكري الامراض الاخرى نحن عاجزين حتى عن
مساعدتهم والمصيبه
الان الوضوء والولاده خاصه لا يحتاجون
لعمليات غيطريه بالامر اضطريت لعمل قيصريه
ببنج موضعي
دي مصيبه يعني دكتوره هويدا تتحدثين بحرقه
كبيره على ما ال اليه الوضع الانساني
والطبي
من تحملنا ان طاقتنا نراهن امامنا
طب يعني يا دكتوره كان هناك تعطل لعدد
كبير من المستشفيات كانت خارج الخدمه بسبب
احتدام المعارك وشدتها اليوم هل عاد بعضها
للعمل ولو اقل جزئيا او تدريجيا حتى
الان حتى احنا مثلا الان نستطيع
اصبح الطريق اصبح الطريق ليس امنا المصيبه
الكبرى الاخرى الان نهب مسلح وترقى
بالطريق لان توفي اخصائي اخصائي جراحه
المناظير بمنزله الان الكعب السوداني داخل
منازلهم يعانون من الخوف والرعب انا عشان
اتحرك مسافه بسيطه من المستشفى الى البيت
لا استطيع
لا استطيع هناك امني ضخم يعني دكتور هويدا
هل جرى اي اعتداء على سيارات اسعاف من اي
طرف
سيارات اطباء
والان انا يا
ريت المستشفى
انا
الموجودين وانما من النهب المسلح
والحراميه والترقى
المصيبه الاخيره الثانيه البنزين هنالك
يعني نقص في هذه
حتى احنا لا نستطيع ان نجلب اخصائي
التخدير طبيب التخدير يسكن قريبا من هنا
الدكتوره هويدا يعني شو الحجه ما الحجه
بان يتم الاعتداء على سياره اسعاف تريد
نقل جرحى مصابين او ان كان قتل حتى
والله انا لا
ادري ما بعرف هو ما يعت
قدوا
لا ادري لماذا
طيب دكتوره هويدا هل من حصيله حتى الان
لعدد ضحايا المعارك وفق الارقام التي
وصلتها من حصيله جديده
بس كم كانت
والله بس ما راجعت الحصيله الاخيره بتوجد
بصفحه اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء
السودان اليوم انا ما شفتها من الوضع اللي
احنا فيه بمستشفى الجديد يعني
كل المنظمات الحقوقيه والانسانيه
طرفي النزاع الحرف فورا فورا واقول ترفيه
نزاع الدم السوداني واحد ارجوكم الانسان
السوداني يموت نحن الان تحت النار
يعني دكتوره هويدا انتم يعني لديكم تحديات
ليس فقط ممن اصيبوا جراء المعارك بفعل
قضاء طائشه او اعير ناريه بل ايضا
الموجودين المرضى الموجودين اصلا في
المستشفى
المستشفى اصلا
الاول يوم كانت اخليت تماما بسبب الرعب
والخوف وكل الاسطاف والكوادر الطبيه كانت
ذهبت الى منازلهم
حضرنا للمستشفى بمناسبه من لجنه المهنبيه
لنغابه الاطباء السودان وفتحنا وعملنا
نداء لكوادر الطبيه التي
وفعلا حضروا الينا ممرضين فني تقدير
وتحضير وهؤلاء هم الليله يوم 14
نفس بالله العظيم الاسطافيه ينام وهو
جالسا
ينام وهو جالسا وانا لا اعتقد انه هذا لهم
وانما دوخ
يعني نفس الاسعاف موجود
يعني لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
اليوم اسبوعين
ناهيك عن القلق لاسرنا الموجودين بعيدين
عننا يعني كمان عندنا اسر وعندنا
يعني والقلق عليهم يعني وحتى الظروف اللي
احنا بنشتغل فيها يعني ظروف يعني تحكي
يعني حتى لا تعقيم كويس لمده جرعات كامله
شو اللي بينقصكم الان دكتوره هويدا في
المستشفى يعني ابرز الحاجات الطبيه
ترفيه عنقنا الان اكسجين ينقصنا اطباء
تخدير لا يوجد اطباء تقدير ينقطع اطباء
تقدير تنقطنا مشاعري حتى المشرب
توقوس لمعينات شاش وقطن
طب الالم تتواصلوا ربما مع منظمات صحيه
عالميه لامكانيات الضغط ربما على الاطراف
المتحاربه لكي يتمكنوا من الوصول اليكم
والله يا اختي ناشدنا عبركم عبر قنوات
ومازلنا نراشد وعبركم نناشد الدول الصديقه
ودول العالم ان تمد انا اتحير لماذا يعني
حتى الطائرات التي تاتي الى السودان
مواطنيها يعني لماذا لا يفكرون
يرسلوا مع هذه الطائرات معينات ولو البسيط
يعني
نستكمل هذه التغطيه معكم وجديد الاخبار
والتطورات من السودان ونحن نتابع هذه
الصور والمشاهد من محيط مطار الخرطوم ودخل
الصراع في السودان والمعارك يومه الثاني
عشر على التوالي والتغطيه مستمره على
العربيه الى الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا ابرز الخروقات
التي سجلت اليوم في الخرطوم
نعم ابرز الخروقات التي سجلت اليوم هنا في
مدينه ام درمان هو ما يتعلق بالاشتباكات
التي كانت دائره في المناطق المحيطه
بالكحاب وكذلك الجهاز الجنوبيه من منطقه
ام درمان في هذه المنطقه شهدت او سمع فيها
ذوي لمدافع ثقيله وخفيفه وكذلك الاستماع
لاصوات الرصاص في تلك المناطق في المناطق
المختلفه في محيط
جسر الفتيحاب وكذلك بالقرب من او ليس
ببعيد من جسر ولد البشير وهو جسر صغير جدا
في شارع العارضه
جنوب غرب ام درمان وهو في الطريق الذي
يؤدي الى سوق ليبيا في هذه المناطق فكان
هنالك سماع لذويه الرصاص وكذلك لمدافع
ثقيله وخفيفه مختلفه في تلك المناطق ايضا
كان هناك تحليق لطائرات قبل قليل في مدينه
ام درمان تستهدف محيط لدعوه التلفزيون هذا
الذي تتمرت فيه قوات من الدعم السريع وهو
المعلوم بالضروره ان
قوات الجويه السودانيه تستهدف المواقع
التي تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع
حركه طبيعيه حركه سير سيارات ناس مره في
الشارع شو يتغير
نعم هذه هي المناطق التي كنا نتحدث عنها
دائما وهي المناطق التي لا تشهد اشتباكات
وهذه المناطق هي التي ايضا ياتيها
النازحون من الخرطوم ومن مدينه بحر مناطق
الاشتباكات هذه المناطق تبعد عن مناطق
الاشتباكات الى حد كبير فيها الحياه شبه
طبيعيه كما تشاهدين هناك ازدحام كبير جدا
على محطه وقود وهي التي خلف الان وايضا
ازدحام ايضا في احد الافران لشراء الخبز
لكن هنا المواطنون يشكوون اوضاعا اخرى
تتعلق بالامور الاقتصاديه من شحا المواد
الغذائيه وكذلك الوقود وعدم القدره للوصول
الى اي منطقه من المناطق الحيويه هذه
المناطق اشبه بانها مناطق سكنيه بالكاد
فيها بعض المستشفيات والقليل جدا من
المرافق الحكوميه كذلك ما قصه ارتفاع
اسعار المستلزمات والمواد الغذائيه وحتى
الوقود
الاعر ارتفعت 300 هل هو يعني مسؤوليات
التجار اليوم هم يرفعون يستفيدون من
الازمه ام في غياب سيوله نقديه بالنسبه
للناس
نعم هو الاشكال هنا فيما يتعلق بمساله
الوقود الشح هو في الامداد امداد هذه
المحطات بالوقود يضاف اليه
حينما تحدثنا مع اصحاب محطات مغلقه لانه
بالكاد توجد محطه من محطات الوقود تعمل
الغالب انها مغلقه لا تعمل فهناك بعض
اصحاب محطات الوقود وجدوا يقولون انه اذا
لم ياتهم امر من السلطات بان يبداوا
ويباشروا عملهم في بيع الوقود لن يبداوا
هذا العمل
حفظ امي يضاف اليه الشحف الحركه لانه نحن
نعلم ان العديد من الجسور الان خارج
الخدمه حتى الجسور التي في الخدمه هي فيها
بعض الخطوره تشهد اشتباكات بين الفين
والاخرى في احد ضفتيها هذا الامر يجعل
امداد الوقود ووصوله الى المحطات مساله
صعبه ايضا الامدادات الغذائيه مرتبطه
بالوقود نفسه فهذه الامدادات الغذائيه
تتحرك عبر الشاحنات التي تعبئ وقودها من
هذه المحطات كذلك ايضا الحركه في الطرق
لانه الطرق غالبيتها
الدعم السريع والاشتباكات التي تتجدد
بينها وبين الجيش السوداني في مضادات
الطائرات والطائرات التي تحلق قصفا لهذه
المواقع وهذه السيارات التابعه للدعم
السريع كل هذه الامور تجعل الحركه صعبه
للغايه بالنسبه للمواطنين
كان يشكو ايضا بعض الزملاء وبعض افرادنا
الجاليات السودانيه خارج السودان بانهم
يريدوا ان يقدموا المساعده الماليه اقل
الى اقربائها والمحتاجين اليوم في السودان
كانت مساله المصارف خارج الخدمه في
المناطق مثلا التي عادت الامور اليها
والحياه تمضي بشكل جيد افضل من غيرها هل
حلت المساله ام ما زالت المصارف خارج
الخدمه وبالتالي نتحدث عن غياب سيوله
نقديه وغياب الكاش لدى السوداني
بكل تاكيد المساله الماليه ما زالت كما هي
وهي معضله حقيقيه غياب المصارف وغياب
البنوك التحويلات من الخارج تقف تماما لا
يوجد اي مال يدخل الان الى السودان لان
المصارف مغلقه بنك السودان مغلق كل البنوك
الان لا تعمل فالحركه
طيب يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مع سالم
وبطبيعه الحال هناك مشكله في الاتصالات في
السودان نذهب ونشكر ايضا سالم الهاشمي من
الخرطوم اما على الحدود البريه بين مصر
والسودان تتواصل عمليات الاجلاء عبر معبره
يقصر وارقين حيث اعلنت هيئه الموانئ
البريه المصريه
تجاوز القادمين من السودان الذين تمكنوا
من دخول البلاد عبر المعبرين عشره الاف
شخص قالت في بيان لها ان القادمين من
السودان من مختلف الجنسيات مع تكثيف
العاملين فيلما فدين من اداره الجوازات
والجمارك وغيرها من الجهات الاستيعاب
الكثافه المتوقعه
اذا معنا من معبر ارقين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه مراسل عربيه احمد عثمان
احمد مرحبا بك معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه
معبر ارقين اذا باتا امل الفرين من
الاشتباكات في السودان ما هي اخر المعطيات
المشاهدات لحركه العبور الى الجانب المصري
نعم بالفعل يعني الكاميرا تركز على مشهد
الحافلات التي تعبر كما ذكرتي يعني اكثر
من عشره الاف مواطن تم نقلهم من قسطل ومن
عرجين من خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
المشهد لا يتغير كثيرا استمرار لتدفق
المواطنين المصريين والسودانيين وبنسبه
وبنسبه ايضا من الاجانب الذين قرروا او
فضلوا ان ياتوا من خلال هذا المعبر
بالتنسيق مع كل من السلطات السودانيه
والسلطات المصريه المشاهد هي هي حاله من
الحزن حاله من الصدمه حاله من الارهاق
الشديد التي تسيطر على جميع من يعبرون هذه
المعابر وربما حاله من القلق حول ما هو
قادم الكلي ربما يعني يتجنب الحديث عن
ماراه في السودان الكل يحاول ان يعني يركز
على ربما ما يعني
من رحله للارهاق للوصول الى باقي المدن
المصريه سواء الى اسوان او الى القاهره
ولكن حتى الان هناك استمرار للتدفق
والمتابع يرى بان الارقام تزيد يعني النسب
الحافلات التي تعبر بشكل يومي من الجانب
السوداني الى الجانب المصري من خلال هذا
المعبر تزيد بشكل يومي ما يوحي بان هناك
استمرار في عمليه النزوح من جانب الجانب
السوداني من الخرطوم وغيرها من المدن
الذين ياتون في رحله طويله ومرهقه وشاقه
للوصول الى هذا المعبد ومن ثم
تقريبا 12 ساعه طريق وعره وصعبه لحين
الوصول الى ارقين هل ما طبيعه مثلا
الرعايه والمعاينه الصحيه المصريه التي
يقدمها الجانب المصري
نعم هناك رعايه طبيه هناك مجموعه من
الاطباء هناك مركز اغاثه هناك سيارات
تابعه للهلال الاحمر المصري ووزاره الصحه
المصريه تتابع من يعبر الى الجانب المصري
هناك وقت طويل ليتم في خلال هذه الرحله
سواء فيما يتعلق بالمعبر من جانبه
السوداني في من هنا ما يصل الى الجانب
المصري هناك رعايه لكل من كبار السن
للاطفال للمرضى ولكن هناك ايضا تدقيق امني
مكثف في هذه في هذه المرحله هناك تفتيش
طبعا وتوثيق وهناك اتباع للاجراءات
المتبعه كنا قد تحدثنا من خلال نشرات
سابقه بان ربما هذه الفوضى التي ضربت
السودان خلال الفتره الماضيه قد يزورنا
البعض بانها قد تسلل البعض العناصر ومن ثم
هناك موازنه شديده جدا بينما يتم فعله هنا
في الجانب المصري من تقديم كافه التسهيلات
وايضا لمراقبه وتدقيق لكل من يتم دخوله
سواء افراد او من بضائع الى الجانب المصري
ربما هذا ما يفسر بان هناك استغراق لبعض
الوقت فيما يتعلق بعمليه المرور من الجانب
السوداني الى الجانب المصري بالحديث عن
التدقيق كان هناك قلق بعض التحفظ المصري
قبل ان يتم السماح بعبور
المواطنين الى وايضا الرعايه الجنسيات
اخرى عبر الحدود الى مصر هل حصلت اي حالات
اشتباه باشخاص خصوصا بعد القلق من عبو
الافراد خلفيات ارهابيه او اجراميه
بجوازات سفر مزوره كما اعلن سابقا
حتى الان لم يتم الرصد بشكل علني يعني هذه
الامور تحديدا فيما يتعلق بعمليات يعني
القبض على عناصر ارهابيه او حتى عناصر
جنائيه مربوطه لا يتم الاعلان عنها هناك
تدقيق يتم عن طريق ما يطلق عليه بصحيفه
الجنايات او السوابق الذي يتم الكشف عليها
من خلال الكمبيوتر على المعابر ولكن لم
يتم رصد هناك بالتاكيد قلق وهناك متابعه
مكثفه ولكن لم يتم رصده حتى اذا كان هناك
ربما كان لن يتم اعلانه الى وسائل الاعلام
الى لو كان ربما شخصيا مهمه او كبيره تمت
او حاولت ان تعود الى مصر من خلال هذا من
خلال هذا الاستغلال لهذه الفوضى ولكن بشكل
عام حتى الان يعني كل ما نسمعه من خلال من
يخرجون بانه هناك يعني معامله طيبه وان
هناك ربما بعض الوقت الذي تم من خلال
المعبر في جزئيه السوداني والمصري وهناك
ايضا ربما حاله من الارهاق تسيطر على ما
تبقى من الرحله نحن نقف الان على نقطه تقف
الى اكبر كبيره وهي اسوان مسافه اكثر من
400 كيلو متر نتحدث عن رحله اخرى عبر
الحافلات ستستمر لمده خمسه ساعات او اكثر
للوصول الى مدينه اسوان لمن سيمكز في
اسوان وهم اغلبيه السودانيين ربما في
شخصيات اخرى ربما يفضلون التوجه الى
العاصمه القاهره ونحن هنا نتحدث عن رحله
قد تستغرق اكثر من عشره ساعات اضافيه
وبالتالي هناك حاله من الارهاق بالفعل
تبدو واضحه على وجوه اغلب من يخرجون بعد
هذه الرحله الطويله يشعرون بالامان
لوجودهم في مصر يشعرون ايضا بالقلق من
فكره ما هو القادم هل سينكثون لمصر لفتره
طويله لفتره قليله البعض كان قد اتى ربما
حامل الحقائب صغيره بعد اتى بملابسه ولكن
هناك من يرى بان فكره الوجود في اسوان
تحديدا فكره مرحب بها حيث هناك يعني تقارب
في العادات والتقاليد ما بين اهل السودان
واهل اسوان ولكن فكره العوده مره اخرى
وتداعيات المشهد في السودان يعني المشهد
السياسيا المشهد امنيا المشهد الاقتصادي
في كل الامور هل ستكون هناك عوده قريبه
احد الذين تحدثت اليهم قال لي انا انا قال
لي انا لم اغلق باب بيتي لا اعرف اذا
حينما اعود ساجد في بيتي او ما في بيت
سليما ام لا فهناك حاله من الهرع سيطرت
على الجميع خلال رحله هذه رحله الهروب او
النزوح الى الحدود المصريه بالتاكيد هناك
يعني حاله من الامان لانه وصلوا الى مصر
القادم في مصر سيكون اكثر امانا ولكن
القلق فيما هو له علاقه بمستقبل وجودهم في
السودان هل هي مساله ايام هي الهام مساله
اسابيع هل هي مساله شهور كل هذه الامور
تبدو واضحه من خلال كلمات من التقيناهم
وحالا من القلق حول تبعات مستقبل المشهد
في السودان تاكيد احمد سنكون معك في سياق
النشرات المقبله ضمن هذه التغطيه لنعرف
المزيد والمزيد من التفاصيل من معبر ارقين
على الحدود المصريه السودانيه مراسل
العربيه احمد عثمان شكرا لك
نعود الى الوضع الميداني حيث لا تزال
موجهات مستمره بين الجيش ودعم السريع رغم
الهدنه المعلنه حيث تهم الجيش قوات الدعم
السريع بخرق الهدنه وقال بيان للجيش ان
الدعم السريع نفذ قصفا مدفعيا عشوائيا
لمناطق في محيط القياده العامه واداره
المرافق الاستراتيجيه في البلاد فيما
تتواصل قناصه باطلاق النار في المناطق
المحيطه بمطار الخرطوم وحي المطار السكني
ومناطق في بحر وام درمان بحسب بيان الجيش
الجيش رصد ايضا تحركات كثيفه لارتال
عسكريه قادمه من كردفان ودافور الى
الخرطوم وتعمل جيش ايضا قوات الدعم السريع
باستمرار استخدام المدنيين في الاحياء
السكنيه دروعا بشريه
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه المعلنه من طرفي
الصراع اعلنت تقابه الاطباء السودانيه
ارتفاع عدد الوفيات بين المدنيين الى 295
حاله وفاه بينما تم تسجيل حوالي 1790 حاله
اصابه بين المدنيين منذ بدايه الاشتباكات
وذكرت النقابه ان هناك العديد من الاصابات
والوفيات غير مشموله لعدم التمكن من
الوصول للمستشفيات لصعوبه التنقل والوضع
الامريكي في البلاد
الحديث عن سجن كوبر الذي غادرت منه قيادات
من نظام البشير ابرزهم احمد هارون فهذا
السجن يقع في بحري بالعاصمه الخرطوم يبعد
عن المستشفى العسكري نحو عشره كيلو مترات
اي حوالي سبعه عشره دقيقه بسياره بحسب
الجيش السوداني يرقد الرئيس السابق البشير
في المستشفى العسكري تحت رقابه امنيه قبل
اندلاع الاشتباكات
هذا واظهرت الصور استمرار اغلاق المحال في
السودان بوجه السكان نتابع
برمضان كان عندنا
يعني عشره
كشف رئيس نادي طلاب الحضاري في السودان
ايمن رئيس ان اكثر من 49 طالبا يمنيا
عالقين في سكن الطلاب من دون مياه بسبب
المعارك الدائره بين قوات الجيش ودعم
السريع طبعا
الصوره
وهذا
الموقع فقط كانت تفصلنا عن نقود اكثر في
السكن اللي في حاليا
49 نفس يعني هذا موقع السكن
هذا موقع السكن هنا في الجهه هذه شارع
المطار ومعارفين في شارع المطار في الجهه
هذه في وراء الجهه المقابله في معسكرات
ورق اللي قدامنا هذه في هنا معسكرات برضو
للمخابرات وفي قوات يعني من احد الطرف
الصراع مسيطره على المنطقه
مع استمرار المواجهات يتفاقم الوضع
الانساني وصعوبات المعيشه كما تزداد
المخاوف من شبح الجوع والعطش وشلل حركه
التنقل
موعد السودانيين مع وقف نهائي للقتال يبقى
مؤجلا وكافه الرصاصي لا تزال هي الارجح
على الاقل حتى الان المشهد في العاصمه
يبدو مخيفا محل اقفلها اصحابها بعد نفاذ
المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه منها وتوقف
اسواق الجمله عن العمل ومحل البقاله
القليله التي لا تزال تعمل تكاد تخلو من
البضائع والمتوفر منها تفوق اسعاره قدره
المواطن العادي يعني من كل جهه لا كهرباء
الامويه يمكن يشد عليه هنا والخبز اهو
اربعين دقيقه من 40 الى 60 دقيقه عشان
تقدر اشيل لك
عشر عشرين عيشه
الحمد لله
حامدون وشاكرون رغم قسوه الصراع والاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه
ما بنقدر نجيب منه حاجه لانه في استغلال
يعني حتى لو الباكو بتاع الدقيقه الليله
بثمانيه قريب من محل
صوابير السيارات هذه وكانها بلا نهايه في
ام درمان تصطفوا الى جانب محطات الوقود
رغم يقين اصحابها بخلود تلك الخزانات من
اي وقود ولو توفرت فالاسعار المطلوبه غير
متوفره
ازمات السودانيين تتضاعف مع الانقطاع
المتكرر لخدمات الانترنت والاتصالات
الهاتفيه فضلا عن شح السيوله النقديه
واغلاق البنوك لتبقى اصوات الرصاص
المتقطعه في هدنه هشه لتزيد مخاوف
السودانيين من اطاله امد الصراع حنان
المصري العربي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات